hey y'all here's another matinee review
of a new movie that we saw this week
this was actually a documentary we
rented this on Xbox yeah uh yeah it just
it's either 2019 or 2020 I think it said
2020 on the Xbox yeah yeah this is
badass documentary it's true crime well
I remember we should have it this is
about tank man the guy who made his own
tank toward a dam town up back in wet
2004 2004 it's funny because you had
told me about this news story and you
wanted to because remember when we were
doing like news stories at the beginning
and you told me about it and I read
about it I was like holy crap and then
we just kind of forgot about we were
going to a show on this we were gonna do
a show about it or at least like niche
in it and then I kind of forgot about it
and then we saw the other day that X but
the Xbox rental thing had put up a
documentary about it yeah oh there it is
Jenny there's like that's that guy so
it's like they were like we have to
watch that review it I remember when
this happened it was the 2004 I saw it
on the news and this dude was in this
homemade tank he had his giant [ __ ]
bulldozer and he arm at the top of it he
had like a 50 couple of 50 cals just you
know [ __ ] one of those bolt to action
the other one I think was a Barrett and
he was shooting it the people at the
damn propane tanks out in the field he
was tearing down they toured up the
concrete plant tore down stores he was
just tearing [ __ ] up didn't kill anybody
but thankfully yeah we could have he
could have I don't think he was trying
to he was just trying to destroy all
their businesses and remember when it
happened I was like what the [ __ ] is
this about and later on I heard like
some rumors that came through the media
at that time this was you know pretty
much the old media that he had some beef
with the town and some people screwed
over his business you know and that he
was taking vengeance on them and they
came out with his documentary that
explains it a little bit more detailed
than that I mean first I kind of thought
maybe he had a legitimate beef and it
kind of makes it sound legitimate at
first in the documentary then you find
out do his like suffering from paranoid
delusions he was [ __ ] they didn't
[ __ ] him over
he just thought they did it's just it's
a bizarre story I really recommend it
yeah this was like really a very
compelling documentary I didn't know a
hell of a lot about the case like I read
about it like a while back I think one
of them have happened the dude's name
was Marvin he mayerly I said this
happened in Granby Colorado yeah we
caught him Marv
yeah back in 2004 and I think what ended
up happening was the day after the
incident didn't they say at the end of
this that Ronald Reagan died and so that
kind of over all the media headlines so
everyone just kind of forgot about it
because this was like big news like on
the day it happened because they had
like helicopters and everything like
that like kind of filming his rampage
yeah not a made sense though why people
stopped talking about it first of all it
was a small town very small it was a
bunch of people that knew each other
it's it seemed to be a personal
disagreement no one was killed and the
guy who did it Marv everybody liked him
you you would think that he was just
some kind of raving lunatic but no he
had a lot of friends everybody liked him
nobody knew nobody knew he had any
problem with anybody this he was just
struggling with a mental illness that
only affected him I guess when he was
alone he was hiding it from everybody
else and he was convinced that the
entire town was against him but he
didn't really express this to anybody
nobody knew yeah I feel like he maybe
like cuz if they had a couple of his
friends on there and I guess he kind of
complained about stuff that happened at
the time like he had a muffler shop and
you know they said he could build
anything he was a really good welder and
stuff and he had like a good reputation
like as a businessman in town and it
seems like even though he complained
about like oh they're giving me [ __ ]
about you know you know I bought this
property he bought the property at
auction and like you know trying to like
hook it up to Water and Sewer and he was
thinking that everyone was like out to
get him or like out picking on him
because yeah he only moved to the town I
don't remember where he was from
originally but he only moved to the town
in like 91 or 92 years got out of the
Air Force and was longing yeah there for
six months but he liked it and he stayed
and he kind of
started dating some woman there you know
and he was young he died it like 52 or
53 I think yeah but he was a very
intelligent ex Air Force guy in a really
good welder and he loved a [ __ ]
snowmobile and he had all these buddies
that you know snowmobile buddies and
they loved the dude you know he could
make anything there was a note there was
a family I forgot what they were called
they were kind of Thompson the
Thompson's they were the most wealthy
family in the town yeah they've been
there for like a really long time been
in for generations everything they owned
a lot of the property yet they bought
the property next to his and other
things were building or and the city
told him that he had to get on to the
sewer mains yeah the water in Syria he
claimed that he was being blocked from
getting on the sewer main you know it
was another twenty or thirty thousand
dollars to dig the dam tranch and it had
to go through somebody else's property
he said that you had to go through
Thompson's property he said the
Thompson's weren't weren't letting him
do that that they wouldn't give him an
evening wouldn't get him give him
easement but a lot of this turned out to
be [ __ ] he was recording it he
recorded everything and they play in the
documentaries him complaining about what
was happening but it was just his
perception of it that's what that's what
yanked me out so much about this cuz
like I said I didn't know a huge amount
I was just like oh I thought this guy
all I all I knew really was this guy
like thought he had some beef with the
town whether he really did or not I
didn't know like prior to watching this
and he just like when in a [ __ ] a
rampage he built a [ __ ] tank
essentially like out of a huge bulldozer
and just like knocked a whole bunch of
people and it was well made it was
businesses yeah it's like and it was
scary because like the cops were just
like they didn't know what to do it's
like they're shooting at it they're
trying to blow it up it's like nothing
is working and they couldn't get in
there and it's like he had a ventilation
system inside the tank
he had cameras and the cameras the
visibility out were behind two inches of
[ __ ] solid lexan and then he had
cooking compressed air system to [ __ ]
blow off the lenses because he knew that
debris would be end up on top of tank
because he had over he's planning he
said God had told him that you know God
kept giving him these messes
just that he had to destroy the town
because of the town says so he had this
thing all [ __ ] rigged up hit a 50 out
the front and a 50 out the back there
was no way to get into the tank yeah he
got into the [ __ ] bulldozer first and
then lowered this tank haul over the
[ __ ] bulldozer and sealed himself
inside he had no intention to come out
alive
they set the SWAT team down there
eventually I'm not gonna tell the whole
story but they said the SWAT team to
blow a hole in the side of tank they
used to [ __ ] - breaching charges they
couldn't get through it didn't even
[ __ ] scratch it yeah
they eventually just had to cut through
the tank when they found him he was dead
it's just yet this is like an amazing
story and it's really fascinating
because at first they kind of make you
because they recorded a whole bunch of
tapes like he recorded himself talking
like before he went and did this um kind
of like airing his grievances and saying
why he was doing it and at first he
seems almost sympathetic like you think
maybe he has the meat like I'm not
saying that what he did that was like
way over the top obviously but you think
oh well you could understand why he
would be mad but then like as it goes on
and they start expanding and like
talking to other people in the town and
stuff like that you start to realize
that he's imagined in this that he's
yeah that it's like like a total
delusion that he's like misinterpreting
things like everyone is like persecuting
him it's almost Aaron would
schizophrenia I think it was paranoid
schizophrenia and I think he was he was
intelligent and he was somehow able to
hide his paranoid schizophrenia from
other people but in private this is what
he was thinking
nobody was [ __ ] him over he bought
that piece of property for $40,000
later on the Thompsons built stuff
around his property that actually would
have allowed him to get into the sewer
system for much much cheaper than it was
originally going to be because they
could just tie into there right it was
closer and then later on the Thompsons
bought his piece of property and here's
nothing
is that the Thompsons being around him
didn't affect his business at all he was
still making money yeah so he was
claiming that he that he was being cut
off from the public but he wasn't he was
still had lots of customers he was
making money it's not like they built a
muffler another muffler shop right next
door they ran like a submits the cement
right yes it was a cement coming and
then so and then later on the table
cents purchased his lot and his little
shed for $400,000 in November it was
that other guy yeah I can't either way
he was not losing money yeah he was
making like 10 times but he made 10
times his money back off that damn like
10 cars after he bought it yeah he made
a lot of money and then they rented it
back to him or so he could stay there he
didn't even have to leave he didn't want
to he got $400,000 yeah out of that but
he could have taken the $400,000 and
bought a better lot yeah yeah I mean
somewhere closer to where the to where
the customers were ISA this whole he was
being [ __ ] over thing I bought into it
for a few minutes watching the program
but then the more I found out about is
us to do his tripping yeah a successful
business and he was making his [ __ ]
that's what was so scary and what I
found so compelling is that someone at
first who kind of seems like like I said
what he did was not excusable seem like
he had a legitimate beef but it seemed
like he had a legitimate beef but then
as it goes on it's it's really
frightening to think how people once
they get an idea in their head that
they're being lino persecuted or that
everyone's out to get them and how every
single thing that happens like feeds
back into that yeah well he wasn't
normal though it was actually it was
definitely some kind of paranoid
schizophrenia it was a paranoid delusion
and nobody knew like no one really said
he was hide what he was up to he was
hiding his feelings from other people
yeah so so nobody didn't call attention
to it people thought he was just happy
read normal guy yeah that's like
terrifying he was fine but when he was
by himself he thought they were all
coming after him
that he was and he actually built a tank
to get revenge yeah for some kind of
perceived wrong that never happened it's
crazy yeah it's a crazy crazy story
run and I should say I mean this
documentary is really really good I
really have like a [ __ ] ton of
interviews like all the people in the
town they play like a large large chunks
of the tapes that he laughed they have
they do like really really nicely filmed
like reenactment reenactments for stuff
that they didn't have yeah news footage
up they do have a lot of news footage
yes and then it [ __ ] and that tells the
whole story what he thought what was
really going on and then it [ __ ]
builds up to the day his Mad Max assault
onto the [ __ ] town and they actually
playing Mad Max the music from mad mad I
know he's going mad a cheesy way but
yeah yeah it's like it's like you know
we're there there actually it's gonna
take the cops can do nothing it's gonna
be hours for the National Guard to
actually get a tank and another tan on
[ __ ] line up there to [ __ ] destroy
this thing this is a hundred tons of
homemade tank he's a year and a half
it's unstoppable okay and they're
actually getting like other heavy
equipment used for Road building and
shift to try to ram him
they even actually a guy got a damn
front-end loader and he tried to buck
and turn the thing over there's no way
because the thing weighs a hundred tons
Jesus you're not gonna move it and it
could move anything out of the way
they're showing helicopter footage of
him going up to buildings and just
putting the blade on the wall the
building then just running down the
length of the building and then the
building just [ __ ] collapsing then
he'd move on to the next one
this [ __ ] Bazaar is outstanding it's
exactly good yeah it actually
outstanding it's a fascinating
documentary it's like it's terrifying
and compelling and just goes to show you
what one man can do if he's got a skill
and [ __ ] willpower
yes Peter he's crazy and this particular
kid well I feel sympathetic for him
though he thought something had happened
yeah it didn't happen but he thought it
did he was mentally impaired yeah by
this you know
mental illness he didn't kill anybody I
was really glad yet I mean that's Troy
in the town because he thought that the
town had destroyed his business but
nothing could have been further from the
truth he had a successful business the
[ __ ] ten-time tenfold increase
on his sucking investment how is that
destroying that's what I mean I was like
man I wish somebody would buy some of my
[ __ ] $100,000 I've never complained
about anything ever again that's a real
estate dream
ya know be good to get a ten-time return
on your own investment if anything the
[ __ ] town showed him much love but in
his mind they were all out to get him
yeah so his second the I went out you
know the the documentary was rated four
and a half stars I went [ __ ] rated a 5
it's a lot it's really good it's really
really fascinating and like I said you
know if you didn't know a lot about the
Kate and like I said it's you know
something that a lot of people forgot
about I guess because you know the news
cycle you know the big [ __ ] happened the
next day and so a lot of people forgot
and like you said no one got killed
although it easily could I mean people
easily could have been killed his main
what he thought who was his nemesis but
it was actually a guy who helped him
which is the guy thrown the concrete
yeah I think everybody liked him yeah he
ran up on the tank with the front-end
loader was trying to stop it from
tearing down the concrete plant he could
have shot the guy with the 50 but
instead he shot the shovel in the front
of it so I don't think Marv actually was
trying to kill people he was just trying
to get even for the loss of the
perceived loss of his business he didn't
lose his business yeah he made 10 times
back on it and they didn't ask him to
leave yeah you know it just it was just
crazy you know it was just fascinating
to me his body can almost like out
almost out of thin air invent a
narrative in veterinary like once once
he had that idea in his head it's like
every single thing that happened he was
like more evidence of that yeah and
because of for instance he thought that
God was telling him to do this and one
of the
main things evidence that God told her
to do it is that the the bulldozer the
front-end shovel the bulldozer barely
fit into the [ __ ] shop yeah it was
like by an inch and this is a big old
any ghosts well of course God says I
have to do this yeah he's like cuz what
if cuz he bought it in an auction I got
without decking like hoping and he's
like so when he gotta beg he's like what
if I have bought the big one bigger one
that I was looking at it's like yes this
shows that it was meant to happen you
can only just fit right yeah anything
and he didn't have children or a family
so therefore that was more evidence that
God said that he should do this yeah and
he's right and this is in his own words
you know you can hear his own words cuz
he recorded it at all yeah you recorded
like three or four and it's long it's
great they keep layering it into the
documentary so you know what it is he's
thinking at the time I thought Marv was
actually a sympathetic character he was
wrong but but I understand why why yeah
he did it you know I mean I mean if that
[ __ ] had been true yeah and it would be
mad but but it wasn't true it was just
mental illness yeah which yeah yeah but
what's weird is that one thing you
learned is that mental illness has
nothing to do with competency this dude
was extremely competent well yeah he can
build a one man tank and he thought that
[ __ ] [ __ ] through it was totally
indestructible
it didn't take him long to build it a
couple of years it had leaps pneumatic
air things to like blow dust off of the
lenses lenses of the cameras it
shouldn't thought of [ __ ] everything
yeah I was impressed yeah the [ __ ]
tank worked yeah it's just one man
working alone at night nobody knew he
was building it yeah cuz he kept it like
his nightly yeah and then and him being
able to hide it was was adding to the
evidence in his mind that God had told
him to do this and then the same guy
could have friends and go downtown
everybody thought it was normal
everybody liked him ya know be
snowmobiling he had like yes big group
of guys he went snowmobiling they just
thought he was awesome yeah and you know
he just had a mental illness he can
function normally around people but when
he his biomes
self he'd start to imagine things and
this is the narrative that he was
imagining yeah that they were all out to
get him they were all laughing at him
behind his back and they were scoffing
at him and they were all plotting his
you know demise and trying to run him
out of town and that it's just his
imagination and human mind it's the
other thing yeah man yeah but yeah so
seriously the minds a hell of a drug
because like I said that's no this is
the only filter you have to you know
kind of interpret what you see around
you in the world that if this if
something is amiss in here and you don't
know about it then your input is going
to be skewed yeah that's like a really
frightening thing to think yep they
showed a lot of real footage of him
running over parked cars running over
cop cars he knew who everybody's car was
he knew where all the business was yeah
this mall is a real small town he had a
whole plan on he had a whole hit list of
all the little targets he was gonna hit
but you know he didn't hit them all of
course you'll see what happened to me
you know but it's a good documentary it
really is yeah it's it's on streaming
right now and it's called tread yeah and
you should seriously go check that [ __ ]
out the crazy okay thank you wanted to
do a show on it would have made a good
show but our show wouldn't do justice to
it the [ __ ] to see the documentary
yeah and like it's really nicely shot to
do you know it's almost like an action
movie it's but yeah definitely go check
it out on streaming it's I think on the
Xbox it was of what 399 499 something
like that yeah when I go Renton it's
like it's it's really fascinating
you